Matthew Spalding associate vice
president Dean of educational programs
for Hillsdale College in Washington DC
welcome to the Kirby Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship a
longtime centerpiece of our work in the
name of the center and of Hillsdale
College is the center around the
principles of the Declaration
independence in the Constitution liberty
and equality that consent of the
governed the meaning of the first
document working its way out through the
rule of law the second document
especially in its words and structure
the idea of separating out the
legislative power from the executive
power the judiciary from both we have
also focused much of our work on the
debate over those precise things
stemming from the progressive movement
about new ideas of how to organize or
structure to talk about our principles
new ideas of governance what they call
the administrative state this new form
has played out over the course of the
20th century and in its increasingly
dominant in the current debate the
question being addressed by our speaker
today is is this new form which it
really is a new method a new form is it
itself lawful or is it merely
necessitated by modern society in a new
forthcoming book published by the
University Chicago Press do out any day
now Phillip Hamburg has taken a long
view an older and historical view of
this precise question and he argues that
what we face today this idea of
administration of government ruled by
regulators had its origin long ago and
that the resistance to that same thing
gave rise to another thing
constitutionalism which is to say that
this is an older and more profound
question than merely the latest
regulatory move of modern government
Phillip hamburger is the Maurice and
Hilda Friedman professor of law at
Columbia Law School he writes very
widely unconstitutional law in its
history and in 2002 wrote another
wonderful book on legal history of the
separation of church and state for
Harvard University Press previously he
taught at the University of Connecticut
Law School
at George Washington University Law
School in the University of Chicago Law
School I'm very pleased to have
professor Hamburg with us here today
and I look forward to this this talk and
his important scholarship which is
coming out soon please join me in
welcoming him thank you
so is administrative law unlawful there
are many complaints about administrative
law that it is arbitrary that it is a
burden on the economy that is an
intrusion on freedom the question
addressed by my book and by this talk is
different question is is administrative
law unlawful although others have
addressed this question in terms of
doctrine my focus is going to be
unconstitutional history those who
forget history are doomed to repeat it
and I suppose those of us who don't
forget it
are doomed to watch others forget it and
suffer under the consequences and this
is what has happened under
administrative power administrative law
is commonly defended as new a new sort
of power a product of the 19th and the
20th centuries modern power that
developed to deal with the problems of
modern society in all of its complexity
and thus allegedly could not have been
anticipated by the Constitution and so
was not barred by it my thesis in
contrast is that administrative power is
actually very very old it revives what
used to be called prerogative or
absolute power and that thus is exactly
what the Constitution developed in order
to prohibit constitutional law developed
nor to prohibit absolute power but we as
a nation have forgotten this and we
therefore now suffer under new
bureaucratized version of absolute power
before beginning I want to say just a
little about historical method not the
most interesting topic I know but it's
worth mentioning first my focus is not
original intent instead the goal is to
recognize the original danger the danger
that constitutional law sought to
prevent ratso rather than focus on
original intent my focus will be on
something like a constitutional version
of original sin second although the
method is a star called the goal is
conceptual one doesn't have to leave
with a lot of facts one should leave
with our few simple concepts because I
think the history reveals or ricans
capitalization of administrative law and
so by looking back at the past we should
be able better to deal with the present
and the future to understand what is at
stake I want to begin by explaining what
I mean by administrative law there are
many possible definitions and the one
that matters here is historical put
simply administrative acts are binding
or constraining edicts that come not
through law but through other mechanisms
throughout their pathways for example
when an agency issues a rule
constraining Americans barring some sort
of pollution or land-use this is an
attempt to exercise binding legislative
power not through an act of Congress but
through other sorts of edicts an
administrative edict similarly within
when an agency adjudicates an
administrative violation imposing a fine
or some other penalty this is an attempt
to exercise binding judicial power not
through a judicial act but again through
an administrative act now leave aside
for a moment whether or not these
administrative edicts are unlawful what
makes them administrative is that they
bind Americans not through law north of
the decisions of a court of law but
through other mechanisms so you can
think of administrative law as a form of
off-road driving right the Constitution
generally offer offers three no sorry
two avenues of binding power acts of
Congress and acts of the courts drill
acts and statues but the executive
prefers to drive off-road not through
statutes not through visual acts but
along other administrative pathways and
for those in the driver's seat this can
be quite exhilarating of course for the
rest of us it's just a little unnerving
this understanding of administrative
power in terms of binding edicts
excludes of course much executive action
so when I complain about administrative
law my complaint is not about government
benefits or privileges you know it's not
about welfare Social Security and my
complaint is not about orders to
officers within their
constitutional authorities executive
officers for example and distributing
welfare instead the problem consists of
attempts to bind or constrain Americans
legislatively or judicially to acts
other than acts of Congress in acts of
course but on this understanding of
administrative power of course
administrative law is a constitutional
puzzle our government is full of puzzles
but none are more serious than that
administrative power the immediate
problem is that administrative power
does not match the powers authorized by
the Constitution the Constitution
authorizes three types of power right
legislative power and Congress executive
power and the president and his
subordinates and digital power in the
courts but what then is administrative
power a fourth type of power it's been
suggested as much by many of its
advocates but then how is it
constitutional my talk today will lay
out two possible answers and both are
framed in terms of history the first and
conventional answer to the
constitutional question comes in a
constitution in a conventional or sunny
vision of the history this conventional
vision emphasizes the modernity of
administrative law there are many
doctrinal justifications for
administrative law and we can talk about
them later if you want but the
foundational justification is that
administrative law is modern or novel
and thus without much serious history
from this perspective administrative
power begins in 1887 when Congress
creates the interstate interstate
commerce commission an administrative
power then just repeatedly expands every
several decades in response it's said to
American society in the early nineteen
hundred's 1930s 1970s and even more in
the last several years a variant of this
account the sunny rosy view comes from
Jeremy Shaw who suggests that
administrative law actually is a little
bit older than it began to develop in
the early practices of the federal
government but even that count of
administrative law maintains the gist of
the standard version the standard
history whether begins in the 1790s or
in 1880s is that this is opposed
1789 development a pragmatic response to
practical problems American life
although it's not mentioned the
Constitution this sort of law allegedly
is in indigenous and empirical growth
which necessarily arose to deal with the
programmatic realities again of American
life it's almost a theological mantra
well the conventional vision obviously
turns out to be in this form very much
an apology for administrative power
sociologically the message is it's about
modernity and necessity administrative
law is a modern type of power necessary
to handle complexities of our lives
it thus is anti modern in quixotic to
resist this power I guess I'm anti
modern and quixotic but you may have
guessed that constitutionally the
message is that administrative law
developed after the adoption of the
Constitution administrative power thus
allegedly could not have been
anticipated by the Constitution and
therefore even if it's not amongst the
Constitution's powers it's a necessary
and modern addition it's a very
reassuring story if you believe in the
justifications are powerful in the
conventional vision of the history post
Constitution Sesa tea sliced through the
tripartite divisions of power on the
government and justify entirely new
approach in the standard vision it's a
pragmatic necessity for the executive to
exercise on the executive power but also
legislative judicial power all three in
one branch you know look ma no hands I
can do it all in one it's the standard
vision it's a pragmatic necessity to
adjudicate disputes without judges and
juries if agency can even be a
prosecutor or a judge and jury in the
standard vision it's a pragmatic
necessity for the due process of law and
indeed all procedural rights to be put
aside when you adjudicate in the
executive branch this is they say all
the process that is due and in the
standard vision it's a pragmatic
necessity for judges to defer not
exercise independent judgment but defer
to executive interpretations of law and
so forth you know the rest
but there are problems with this
conventional history and its
justifications and the most basic
question can Oracle accuracy is it true
that administrative law is a modern post
constitutional American Development is
it true that the Constitution could not
have anticipated administrative law and
did not prohibit it ultimately this
conventional history I propose does not
dig deep enough it is a cheerful breezy
vision of history in which the past does
not examine to lightly and all the
sweetness and light so let's turn to a
second vision a much darker vision which
looks below the surface of the usual
apologetics and sees a very dim and
dismal past in fact administrative power
revives absolute power rather than a
modern necessity it is a version of a
recurring threat one inherent in human
nature and the temptations of power the
constitutional history of the past
thousand years in common law countries
at least records the repeated Edmund
flow of absolutism on the one side and
law on the other there always have been
pressures for absolutism and law only
sometimes has been able to resist during
the next ten minutes or so we will
examine the history of absolute power
and as I recount it please think about
the modern parallels I may be talking
about medieval or 17th century Kings but
you should be thinking ahead of me about
contemporary presidents and not just the
current president the last century of
presidents we need to begin with
prerogative power English Kings were
widely expected to rule through law they
had Parliament for making law and courts
of law for adjudicating cases and Kings
were expected to govern through the acts
of these bodies thus to bind their
subjects in general they needed to seek
Acts of Parliament and to bind their
subjects in particular cases they needed
to go to the courts for acts of the
courts but Kings were discontent with
governing through the law they wanted
more than they could get when going to
the legislatures in courts and they
often acted on their own not through
but through royal or prerogative power
the power ordinarily exercised through
law thus was evaded when Kings acted
through prerogative power prerogative
power thus was the predecessor of
administrative power prerogative power
was the personal power of Kings
administrative power is the
bureaucratized power of states but
otherwise they are similar they both
have been evasions of law consider these
prerogative innovations and they should
sound familiar if you have any
experience with administrative law
original ordinarily Kings bound their
subjects through statutes but through
their prerogative power they bind
subjects through proclamations or
decrees what we call rules or
regulations ordinarily Kings repeal old
statutes by obtaining new statutes but
through the prerogative power they
issued prerogative dispensations and
suspensions what we call waivers right
ordinarily Kings could enforce the law
only through the courts of law but with
a prerogative power they enforced their
extra legal commands in their own
prerogative or extra legal courts
notably the King's Council the Star
Chamber and the High Commission where
the due process of law gave way to
inquisitorial process drive from the
civil law what we call administrative
process ordinarily judges resolve
disputes about royal power in the court
of the law and their own independent
judgment but I counted the prerogative
power Kings expected deference from
judges they expected deference to
prerogative regulations to perogative
interpretations of statutes what we call
the Chevron problem and deference to
prerogative fact-finding the
administrative record
interestingly though 17th century judges
refused to defer on the whole something
has changed last but not least
prerogative power evaded English
divisions of power they did not yet have
a full separation of powers but they did
have a basic division of powers
Parliament had power to make laws the
law courts the power to adjudicate and
the King had the power to exercise force
it isn't that
and from what we're familiar with
nonetheless when Kings acted to their
prerogative power they or their
prerogative courts what we call their
administrative agencies exercised all
government powers in one for example the
Star Chamber could make regulations
prosecute infractions and adjudicate
them all in one agency evidently
prerogative power was a means of aiding
government through law and just as Kings
evaded law with prerogative power the
executive now evades law with
administrative power the defenders of
this sort of prerogative or
administrative power described it as
absolute power this is not an accusation
this was their defense this is their
justification they were proud of it
of course the phrase absolute power can
have many meanings but at once was used
in very concrete ways to describe the
prerogative administrative power that
evaded the law precisely what made this
power absolute here we get to the
conceptual payoff conceptually there
were three central elements of absolute
power absolute power was extra legal
super legal and consolidated first
absolute power was extra legal it was
actually gonna sense that it bound the
public not through law but through other
sorts of edicts for example when Kings
bound their subjects not through
statutes but through prerogative decrees
rules regulations they acted extra
legally not through law but through
another means when they Kings made
adjudication binding their subjects not
through the acts of the law courts but
through prerogative adjudications they
acted again extra legally that's the
first way in Parag we much prerogative
or today administrative power was
absolute is that it was an extra legal
power exercised not through law but
outside it the second absolute element
of power was that was super illegal it
was super lutein VI made these terms
turn up amongst naval philosophers I'm
not inventing these terms these were the
terms of the day used it was super legal
in the sense that Kings expected judges
to defer to it judges had a duty to
exercise their own independent judgment
in accord with the law of the land they
could not defer to others Parliament
even passed statutes frantic oaths not
to defer to the king or the Kings
letters this was a strict requirement
already in the 14th century Kings
therefore could not impose extra legal
power unless they could evade review in
the courts and Kings therefore insisted
that much of their prerogative was above
the law
that it was super legal and from this
perspective because it was above the law
judges they said have to defer to the
prerogative decrees the prerogative
interpretations of statutes and
prerogative adjudications deference to
prerogative or administrative power
that's depended on this power being
super legal and this is the second way
which was absolute again it sounds
familiar doesn't it third absolute power
was consolidated it was consolidated in
the sense that it United all government
powers in the king or in his prerogative
courts again what we call administrative
agencies when prerogative or
administrative bodies made law
adjudicated and executed they obviously
worked combining all powers of
government in one prerogative or
administrative power thus could be
absolute in three basic ways extra legal
super legal and consolidated underlying
these three elements was the usual
conceptual justification for absolute
power necessity necessity it was said
has no law it does stood apart from the
law and it rose above it if their effort
was the repeated justification for extra
legal super legal and consolidated power
so where it's common lawyers rested on
the law of the land the king attempted
to evade and defeat claims of law with
claims of necessity let's look at some
historical examples much of the history
of the common law can be understood as
repeated responses to absolutism when
King John calls Englishmen to account
extra legally in his council you're not
through the courts but just run him in
front of him in his and his bureaucrats
the Baron's in Magna Carta in 1215
demand that no freemen shall be taken or
imprisoned or deceased nor will
king sent for him you can't even send a
summons except by the lawful judgment of
his peers by the law of the land
when 14th century English Kings
questioned Englishmen in the King's
Council Parliament in 1354 1368 enacts
the first due process statutes requiring
the king to act through the due process
of law this is again the same issue we
face today when 14th century Kings sorry
when James this when James the first
attempts to make law extra legally
through proclamations the early 17th
century the judges respond in 1610 with
an opinion that binding proclamations
executive acts attempt to bind people
like a statute were unlawful and void
when James demands judicial deference to
prerogative interpretations of statutes
as one of his actually pet concerns he
wants what we call Chevron deference the
judges refuse they don't go along with
it
indeed in 1641 Parliament abolish as the
prerogative courts the Star Chamber the
High Commission which were the bodies
that engaged next with legal law making
in education and was profoundly the
English defeat absolute prerogative
power by developing ideas of
constitutional law English Constitution
of course was lost in the mists of time
if it ever really existed but it was
said to be the source of all government
power and it was said to place
legislative power in the legislature in
judicial power in the courts the
Constitution therefore made clear that
there was no extra legal super legal or
consolidated power and the US
Constitution echoes all of this it
echoes his response to absolutism early
Americans were very familiar with
absolute power they feared this extra
legal super legal and consolidated power
because they knew from history could
have made all law and all legal rights
and therefore is no surprise that they
framed the Constitution to bar this sort
of power to be precise
Americans established the Constitution
as the source of all government power
and they used the Constitution place
legislative power in the legislature and
judicial power in the courts though thus
could be no extra legal super legal or
consolidated power well but that's
nonetheless absolute power has come back
to life in common-law lands after
absolute power was killed off in England
and America it's circled back
oddly enough from the continent through
Germany and especially Prussia
although extra legal power was defeated
England in America it survived and
flourished in civil law countries most
prominently in France and Germany there
what once was the personal prerogative
power of Kings became the bureaucratic
administrative power of the states and
the Prussians were the leader of this in
this development in 17th and 18th
centuries they were the Puntland and in
the 19th century they become the primary
theorists of administrative power and
they celebrated but into hide they
celebrated its absolutism and they
celebrated its defeat of constitutional
law and constitutional rights which they
mocked and strangely this was the source
of American administrative law thousands
upon thousands of Americans studied
administrative power in Germany you
couldn't get a job I teach at Columbia
University you could not get a job
teaching political theory in Columbia
unless you'd studied German
administrative power you had to actually
go Germany and most actually in German
degrees now the studying of German law
was not enough to revive absolutism but
at the same time progressives were
becoming increasingly discontent with
elected legislators and men in courts
this in fact was probably not a
political matter but a class matter but
that's another matter you can read my
book if you're interested progressives
increasingly sought to evade rule
through and under law and they therefore
embraced German theories of
administrative power they adopted
absolute mysteries of extra legal law
making adjudication absolutist theories
of deference to super legal power
including interpretation and absolutist
theories about consolidated state power
and they justified all of this by
insisting that necessity defeats law
especially constitutional law
progressives were / understood what they
were doing this wasn't a hidden agenda
they taught this in our finest
universities and as late as 1920
after many of them to go quiet on the
subject when they realized it was
politically unpalatable even John
Dickinson writes in 1927 the question of
whether or not the king can issue
ordinances parallels our modern question
as to whether or not an executive body
or officer can establish regulations and
the arguments prone con have followed
much the same lines again he knew
exactly what he was doing there thus is
a direct intellectual connection between
medieval absolute power and modern
administrative power it's not merely a
revival it's the same thing the same
intellectual tradition which circled
back from the continent so what the
English defeated in the 17th century and
what Americans rejected in 18th century
Europeans and the especially the
Prussians preserved and developed and
from there Americans reintroduce it back
into America absolute power thus has
been continuous and although it once was
defeated by constitutional law it has
come back and triumphed over the past
120 years Americans have reestablished
the very sort of power that the US
Constitution most centrally forbade
administrative law disturb and repeating
myself perhaps but it's worth driving
home administrative law is extra legal
and that it binds Americans not through
law but through other mechanisms not
through statutes but through regulations
not through decisions of Courts but
through other adjudications it is super
legal that it requires judges to put
aside their independent judgment the
very office of being a judge and defer
to administrative power once again
bowing to it as if it were above the law
and it is consolidated and that it
combines three powers of government in
government it's rated agencies
absolutism has returned its dark vision
of history has powerful constitutional
implications in general the history
shows that the Constitution barred this
extra legal super legal consolidated
power regardless of when you call it
prerogative or administrative this is
what the Constitution most centrally
forbade but the history is also power
when we get into specifics and I've ever
want to close this talk with some
examples of how the history so darkly
illuminates and familiar constitutional
problems
there are many possible examples and you
can read about them in my book because I
think they be used to litigation amongst
other things but it could suffice to
discuss two of them delegation and
procedural rights one standard defense
of administrative power power is
delegation for example to said that
Congress delegates its lawmaking power
to administrative agencies and they then
use this power to promulgate regulations
from this perspective it does not matter
that the regulations are extra legal
because Congress has delegated its
lawmaking power but this is a very poor
defense in the past the delegation of
lawmaking was actually a familiar
feature of absolute power
this is not something newfangled that
solves the problem when Kings exercised
extra legal power they usually had at
least some delegated authority from
Parliament or at least an ambiguity that
could run with for example Henry the
eighth issues binding proclamations
under a statute he obtains called the
act of proclamations which authorizes
him to do this yet even with legislative
delegation his binding proclamations
were understood to be exercises of
absolute power and in centuries later
particularly the 18th century the act of
proclamations is condemned as
unconstitutional David Hume no Whig says
this when Parliament gave to the Kings
Proclamation the same force as a statute
enacted by Parliament it made by one act
a total subversion of the English
Constitution the delegation of
legislative power thus was a familiar
aspect of absolute power how does the
Constitution respond it expressly bars
the delegation of legislative power I
know that may seem odd to those of you
who may have studied this it's widely
said for example by Cass Sunstein that
the Constitution does not expressly bar
the delegation of legislative power but
read the Constitution indeed the first
words the Constitution's very first
substantive words are all legislative
power herein granted shall be vested in
Congress the very first word all
precluded delegation you see if all
legislative powers are in Congress none
of them can be elsewhere
it's not an accident that the word all
was put there it was put there precisely
to bar delegation evidently the
delegation of legislative powers was a
familiar problem the most serious of
problems and the Constitution responded
by expressly barring it there's a lot
more that we can say about delegation
let's leave that aside we move on to one
other example a second constitutional
problem that was illuminated by this
dark vision of history is the
administrative denial of procedural
rights administrative adjudication
evades almost all the Constitution's
procedural rights it offers some minimal
protections but even in cases that are
criminal nature its subjects Americans
to adjudication without real judges
without Curie's without grand juries
without full protection against
self-incrimination and without other due
process of law and so forth you can just
run through the Bill of Rights
indeed like the old prerogative courts
administrative courts substitute
inquisitorial process for the due
process of law and by the way that's not
just an evaporator all abstract
accusation about inquisitorial process
it's exactly what her a lot of early
administrative law was deliberately
modeled on and so administrative Duty
ation becomes an open Avenue for evasion
of the Bill of Rights and procedural
matters the standard justification is
the procedural rights apply centrally to
what the government does in courts not
entirely to what the government does in
administrative areas in fact it's only
through the generosity of the courts
that we get some little protection in
administrative matters hence the famous
perversion of due process that
administrative agencies provide all the
process that is due isn't that funny
but the history shows the procedural
rights developed primarily to bar
prerogative or administrative
proceedings not on the side it was the
main focus not really to regulate what
the government does in the regular
courts of law the principle of due
process of law has already suggested
develops as early as the 14th century in
statutes which attempt to prevent the
exercise of judicial power by the King's
Council it's not about the law courts
primarily it's about what happens
outside the courts Englishmen develop
due process into a constitutional
principle in the 17th century in
opposition again to the prerogative
courts
it therefore is clear that the due
process of law
centrally barred extra legal
adjudications not really wayward
adjudications in court simile just take
another example these procedural rights
the right to a jury develops primarily
in opposition to prerogative or
administrative proceedings not merely as
to court proceedings one of the problems
with perogative adjudication 17th
century is that denies defendants their
right to a jury right that's one of the
complaints about it early Americans
understand this danger of administrative
proceedings and indeed some of the very
earliest constitutional cases United
States on the subject in New Jersey in
1780 in New Hampshire and 785 the
regular law courts hold administrative
proceedings before justice the piece
unconstitutional because precisely
because they do not offer juries the
denial of a jury like due process is all
about administrative matters although it
also includes what happens in chorus the
dark history thus powerfully illuminates
the the constitutional problems it shows
the Constitution barred any delegation
of legislative power and that the
Constitution guaranteed due process and
very rights most basically to bar
administrative adjudication again there
are many other examples you can read
about them if you wish but these I think
should show the central force of the
store club analysis now in conclusion
the sunny conventional vision of the
history is utterly mistaken it misses
the entire pre constitutional history it
misses the danger of extra legal super
legal and consolidated power it misses
the recurring and dangerous character of
absolute power
it misses how courts including the sorry
constitutions including the US
Constitution systematically barred
absolute power where the prerogative or
administrative and absolute power was
forbidden if we are to understand
administrative power we need an accurate
history of it an accurate
conceptualization of it and an accurate
vocabulary the first step is historical
we need to recognize the place of
administrative power in the long history
of absolute power on this basis we can
begin to see the danger and can begin to
respond
absolute power was the danger that led
to the development of constitutional law
we there ever can see how the
Constitution barred this threat and how
it is unconstitutional the second step
is conceptual we need to recognize
administrative power as extra legal
super legal and consolidated on this
foundation it becomes apparent that it
administrative powers utterly
incompatible constitutionalism and with
the ideal of rule through and under law
not the vague general notion of rule of
law but the the core common law ideal of
rule through and under law and the third
and final step in this
reconceptualization is to change one's
vocabulary administrative powers thrived
in America because its proponents used
the vocabulary of law to legitimize an
extra legal enterprise therefore to
recognize the realities of
administrative law one must take back
the language of law one must reject the
current legitimizing vocabulary and use
more accurate words which acknowledge
the Grimm book realities administrative
power seems lawful when you speak for
example of administrative law even I've
been doing that right we speak about
administrative courts administrative law
judges or administrative due process to
be accurate we have to speak more
clearly not about administrative law but
about absolute power including extra
legal Superleague
super legal power not about
administrative courts and judges but
about executive officers strain outside
their constitutional authority and we
cannot talk about the due process that
is due or due process the administrative
circumstances but about the
administrative denial of due process
only if we're honest and our very words
can we begin to address the danger so at
stake here is nothing less than the
thousand-year common law effort to
establish governance through and under
law in a brief century administrative
powers revived absolutism it is restored
governance outside and above the law
this gets justified as a modern
pragmatic response to modernity but in
fact it is the recurring danger of
absolutism of extra legal super legal
and consolidated power thank you
thank you stand up I'm just wondering if
the delegation of the congressional
delegation of rulemaking or legislative
powers to the states is as problematic
as the delegation of rulemaking power to
federal bureaucracies and if not whence
the asymmetry thanks from the ministry
of perspective anything that any body
that has more than one person is a
potential administrative agency right so
you can look at a state a unit private
university a church they all become
administrative agencies to carry out
federal well how this is done it's often
actually quite complicated I don't think
it's been sufficiently studied academics
I don't think you paid much attention to
it at all and it's a very serious
problem it just adds an extra layer
because it's also destroying two extra
layers one destroying federalism and
second destroying the product the
distinction between public and private
life and in the universities of course
we face this every day
so yes it's a profound problem in some
ways even more so yes
it seems to me there may be some
complications in this area that I wonder
if you could speak to for example the
Congress in enacting the Administrative
Procedure Act of 1946 and that apparatus
appears to have given a fig leaf so that
agencies can act under color of law and
the judiciary in creating the
administrative conference of the United
States and building a legal
infrastructure around administrative
practices there would seem to lend some
of its authority I wonder if you could
speak to that yes here it gets really
quite depressing doesn't it now it's not
it's nothing it's nothing new that a
legislature will delegate legislative
authority but this is exactly what the
Constitution prevented the APA uses all
sorts of fine language that is designed
to legitimize this enterprise but when
you examine it closely as you I'm sure
you have it all dissolves into mush
right and some of the language is really
quite humorous so for example the
substantial evidence requirement that's
the standard of review traditionally for
reviewing jury decisions since when was
HHS a jury this is very odd juries are
not meant to be
government officials issuing commands
and then deciding and so forth so yes
the the eighth the APA is at best a fig
leaf it's not even a very good fig leaf
it's a rather dry desiccated one isn't
it
now your other question remind me was
about yes the administrative Congress
conference I find very particularly
depressing because of course what an
earth is the judiciary doing the judges
have an office of independent judgment
that is the foundation of all their
authority and it's tempered only by the
qualification they must decide in accord
with the law of the land in cases so
what are they doing becoming as it were
advisors to Congress in adopting that's
what this looks like a set of advisory
opinions and all sorts of judges who
really should know better have been
involved with this
this is very very disturbing oddly
enough but perhaps not a coincidence
this is exactly what James the first
tried to do he understood that if the
judges were not he want the judges not
to be hard on him he had to get them
involved with the administrative proc
ative process so he tried to get them to
issue it advisory opinions and this is
what led to all the early constitutional
law against advisory opinions because
the judges backed off that we can't do
this and this is a formation of modern
constitutional law but the judges seem
to forgotten this so it's very
problematic and I think it gets even
worse because if you think about the
whole process of judicial review of
administrative acts it's I don't want to
go into a lot of technical detail now
but it's devised in a way that actually
brings the judges into the process so
they feel themselves to be actually just
further administrative supervisors of
the administrative process and
responsible for making it work and they
even say this in their cases at which
point the entire judiciary has been
corrupted so part of what needs to be
done sadly is to educate the judges as
to the very nature of our office and how
they've abandoned it something very
sober is happening thank you thank you
very much for your lecture I'm Brittany
Corona I'm over at the Heritage
Foundation across the street I actually
found the most interesting thing you
said was that the absolute power the
administrative state that we're dealing
with is not so much a product of
modernity it's a product of human nature
and kind of harkening back to Federalist
49 when Madison argues that we need to
have a public sentiment Revere rule of
law and I think that your your three
charges history the conceptual
understanding administrative state and
change of vocabulary those are all
educational based can you kind of
elaborate how do we restore public
sentiment to appreciating rule of law it
seems to be the biggest first step into
regaining self sovereignty thank you
good question and allow a friendly
friendly amendment if I will and then
I'll get to the main body the question
the friendly amendment is this one of
the conceptual suggestions I make in the
book and I think is actually very
important is we actually have to drop
the phrase rule of law this may seem odd
but the phrase the rule of law is not
the historic phrase in common law
countries it's actually the rule the
language traditionally used in Prussia
and in Germany but yes isn't that aside
why would this be see the standard
anglo-american approach is rule through
an under law which means you can only
bind people through an act of a
legislature and through a decision
record but the Prussians even most
liberal oppressions and many of them
were very liberal and sought to have a
free society they live in a society
where there these traditions had been
eradicated long before and it's actually
interesting sad history and so the best
they could hope for was an absolute
power that was Barok retired regularize
din made to look like law they called
that the rest out and the notion of rule
of law echoes the notion of a rest at
its on so for example one of the
standard defenses of administrative law
is that it's an accord with the rule of
law because this power comes under the
authority of statues and it's rule it
doesn't involve that much discretion
because there all sorts of rules and
regulations that administrators work
through so I think we have to be careful
with the language even something is
revered as rule of law may not be quite
the right language I think rule through
and under law actually hits home better
now to the to the superb question how
does one do all of this what's what what
do we make of it well it does seem to me
the most important thing actually is not
litigation not going out and make a big
fuss about this but rather a sort of
education but education of the spirit
not just the formal education
universities anything but that perhaps
how is this done these days well videos
you know let me take an example you know
Obamacare has been very illuminating
right it's been an opportunity for
people to feel administrative law so
what is a waiver what is a waiver that
deprives you of the health care that you
thought you had under a statute that's
the oldest Pinole dispensation we've
even had some acts of suspension people
forget this language it's worth
remembering what it is and that this is
absolute
power I think these queries issues
actually are not technical the danger is
we make them very technical complicated
you can turn off but there is at the
heart of the matter something very basic
as to what is the mechanism that
constrains you is it a law made by your
representatives or is it a command an
executive command an elective monarchy
this is not difficult this is actually
very straight for it what is it that
binds you is it a little proceeding in
front of an administrative agency or is
it in a court of law so I I think there
are opportunities here just for
education the broad-minded sense and
after that everything will follow thank
you
aren't the principles you you're
articulating here all at least implicit
if not quite explicit in the particulars
of the Declaration of Independence and
so wouldn't that be a good way of
infusing spiritedness in Americans today
as a document at least used to do thank
you I think in general terms yes and the
the in history of American resistance to
the British it's filled with discussions
of absolute power and many historians
academic historians looking at this say
oh they're just using at words absolute
and Star Chamber the core site that's
just trying to ratchet up the rhetoric
this is just ideological but in fact
they were dealing with some of the same
issues in the 17th century right if you
think about the use of Admiralty courts
to decide common law questions it was
attempt to get a civil a civil law court
to decide common-law questions without
juries and so this was aptly viewed as a
problem of administrative power of
absolute power and so the resistance to
Britain and the and the Declaration of
Independence does capture indeed much of
the spirit what worries me of course is
that the spirit of Independence is not
quite as pervasive I think is at the
time
and one can see that sadly I think you
know universities as much as anywhere
else but I don't think we disagree on
that your remarks seem to have very
significant implications for the
structure of government if you look at
the administrative law growth that we
have it would its rationale has been for
because of the greater complexity of our
lives and the interactions between more
and more people so we have a large
geographic country with a lot of people
in it it seems to me that the actual
practice of what you are suggesting
would require a devolution of political
power down to smaller and smaller
entities we push problems down but they
can be solved at the smallest at the
lowest possible level would you agree
with that or you think there are
implications you think this is actually
doable in large democracies like we have
so that's a lot in this question and
yeah we might just go to your last words
is this doable and democracies maybe
democracy doesn't work but of course I
wouldn't use the word democracy and
democratization of a republic is I think
part of the danger here the progressive
simultaneously talked in populist terms
and sought to remove power to an elite
and so it seems to me democratization
the notion democratization carries some
questions with it does factors does
devolution follow I'm not sure I think
there's good reason to desire to desire
that we stick to our federal system but
I think that's a separate question it's
not what this is about so this question
of administrative power is mirrored at
the state level and it does involve as
we discussed earlier some questions of
federalism but this critique this
particular critique in my book does not
attack that attacked us the growth of
federal power per se it's just about how
it's done so there is another
interesting question there and I don't
know whether we disagree agree on that
but it's just not what this project is
about
is this doable which really is the the
grand objection or is it necessary as
the advocates of administrative law
would say I think increasingly as
administrative power expands and the
level of regulation becomes more
detailed and cloying the answer is maybe
it's necessary to get rid of this the
reality is it said this follows in the
living Constitution and evolution but
let's face it the living Constitution is
a very indefinite thing it doesn't
dictate any particular result and why
does it entrench a system of government
that's developed in the Middle Ages in
the 16th 17th centuries or even one from
the 1880s or even the 1930s the idea
that we have a constitution that's
flexible but doesn't move seems rather
odd so it doesn't see me cut the
constitutional law doesn't stand in the
way I'm the in fact it may require the
opposite let's take one example I know
there's a big question but take one
example I know a little bit about F FDA
regulation because this is an example of
something the regulation of drugs and
devices is something that everyone's
concerned about perhaps we'll get hurt
by Newton by by what new science has to
bring to bear in our lives of course if
you're in this field you'll know that
what will lengthen our lives is not
health care what will length nor more
spending well will lengthen our lives is
the freedom of scientific development
and this is being crushed by the
government in all sorts of ways and if
you what are the incentives for the FDA
to allow science to develop well on the
whole they have a predisposition to say
no not to say yes they stand in if they
have a choice if they've any uncertainty
about the risk of a drug they will more
likely say we will not allow development
we will not allow this to go to market
then they will say I'll take a role
let's see what happens and one of the
results is that their entire fields in
which we now do not have enough
scientific development finally people
begin to pay attention to antibiotics
antibiotics I are now being developed I
think by only four companies because no
one can handle the bureaucratic morass
so FDA regulation is not going to save
our lives it will probably kill up a
large number
us maybe hundreds of thousands of us and
when that happens maybe a little bit
chance to reconsider the FDA not that
I'm looking forward to it the last
question I guess is this your talk is is
profound I think your historical
analysis is really very enlightening my
question to you is how do your
colleagues respond to the audacity of
your argument which is nothing short of
absolutely revolutionary thank you
that's very kind of you I suppose brief
answer can be summed up in the words of
one colleague a very distinguished
scholar of administrative law and you
actually sent this to me an email it
wasn't just orally he said this is
interesting but it's too painful to read
go figure
but seriously I I'm very confident with
the history I've spent my life studying
this history and from manuscript sources
not just printed sources and it's it's
my hope maybe it's a vain hope it's my
hope that actually looking at
administrative law the 20th century can
actually illuminate one study of the
sixteenth and seventeenth centuries and
even the 14th century this sounds odd
one doesn't read history back wrap
backwards that's said to be a Whig
fallacy but actually if one makes a
mistake obscene one-off events and
treating them as sweet generous when
misses a lot if when sees instead a
recurring pattern when then gains
insights into the nature of what was
looking at not just currently but it's
in the past and then one gets back to
the parade profound questions about
human nature so thank you yes the
history actually really does matter here
in ways that were apt to forget we got
the history everything you do is novel
brilliant
necessary if you don't look at this tree
if you do look at the history you one
may act with more modesty thank you
Thank You professor ken reminded me that
we'd always make appeal to the
declaration for making good arguments
not only does it objected the king
refusing to assent to laws for the
common good but what he does do always
want my favorite lines from declaration
he's erected a multitude of new offices
and sent hither swarms of officers to
harass our people and eat out their
substance that's not the administrative
state I don't know what is
professor hamburgers book is
administrative law unlawful due out in a
matter of weeks from University of
Chicago Press highly recommended and
lastly I will note that our next lecture
will be on June 19th dr. David Forte of
Cleveland law living Marshall School of
Law will be speaking on self-government
for the self governed the rule of virtue
and Democratic Republic again thank you
sir and thank you all for coming